over the weekend on Saturday minding my
own business and I get kind of a
threatening video email sent to me by a
mr. Hugh Jackman Kevin I know you're
doing a lot of shows traveling around
the world lots of them like you've been
everywhere around the world except
Australia like it's almost like you
going out of your way not to go to
Australia and I just you know because
we're made so I just want you to know
that it's been noticed
first of all I didn't know Hugh Jackman
was in prison yeah I looked into it
there's an old rule in show business
when Hugh Jackman tells you to do
something you do it ladies and gentlemen
I'm going to Australia
[Applause]
I arrived in Sydney Australia and even
though they speak English here I still
had to learn the language I'm sitting
here with Gabrielle a voice and dialect
coach Sarang
I would like to be able to speak like an
Australian an authentic Australian I do
dialects very well Scottish Loch Ness
monster that's very good
got all the booty British vegetables
travel annoy if the traveler knife for
me this Gavin Captain's Quarters we
you'll come funny poor without starving
the capital beat are you very good
he was rayon accent all happens back
here you gotta hook it into your jaw
cavity Oh rather than forward here stick
it back but as Australia Day yeah yeah
and if you're saying yes to something
it's also really good to go
yeah that's what that's nice for me some
fruit would you like some free
[Applause]
yeah I'll put it down but I did want the
fruit that's with Australians yeah they
turn everything into a nickname yes did
you have you break dad my brekkie
oh that's breakfast right fit oh you
haven't smashed a bow on toast for
brekkie I asked mashed Avalon Towson
record
yeah it's lacking a little subtlety but
the sounds are good I can get subtlety
bad barbecue we said Bobby Oh Bob right
Bobby that's the one everyone knows
shrimp all in the bathroom what do you
say prunes wait a minute there was a
whole commercial it for years I'll sleep
an extra shrimp on the body
you don't say Fred Helen they made fools
out of us tonight the war it's a big
drinking culture here we know it is
Foster's lager Foster's Australian food
beer
nobody drinks Fosters they don't most
bars won't even sell it is that true yes
again yeah I feel like I'm being scammed
my whole life I thought the first thing
you get to Australia have a shrimp on
the barbie without Foster's lager then
you go to Outback Steakhouse
so you talk to Rupert Murdoch about a
kangaroo another thing is that we um we
say how good is something but it's a
rhetorical question we go how good is
this weather now go to this weather so
that I'll go this as well yeah that's it
every that's what so it's like a series
of mild strokes that have included the
back part of my face that's right a row
there's a row and if someone's a bit
daft you can say that there are a few
rows loose in the top paddock few rows
loose in at home yeah there's a few
rules loose in this ha
I'm trying just kill this part of my
face okay you start saying things and
I'll repeat them immediately that's how
we'll do it let's go oh how good is this
weapon how good is it wow bloody
beautiful on a pier huh do you want to
drink
ah you wanna drink all the time but not
foster's lava
you're doing really well how do you say
I'm asexual
I'm so I'm nice and I'm asexual I'm
asexual
oh yeah I think you are now yeah I'm
just loosening it that's working
oh hello is good yeah that's perfect
that's easy right friend mate he's my
mate
get out mate a woman Sheila it's top
Sheila top see though
Sheila bar top cedar [ __ ]
what do you call having a heart attack
having a heart attack okay that step you
don't wanna screw don't mess with Oh
Jackie right
everyone knows ac/dc right yeah what are
we calling you call a lazy Daisy hey you
call um akkad akka a cdc's are easier
akka Becca
they were born here we get to comb what
we want speedos yeah those are cold
wanker Wally's it's a wanker hammock
budgie smugglers buggies
Yoda budgies it's a kind of a bird so
men's junk in a speedo two Australians
looks like a bunch of birds shoved in
just just one just one
yeah not in this case
[Applause]
eisah we blur we blue haze a we blur
your deck eyes a dag you know what a dag
is it's a bit of poo that is on the back
of a sheep's but before it gets Sean and
that's your word for people that like
books and study and use computers
actually better mankind that surprises
me mmm I'm surprised by that Bimini Bob
oh he didn't ask you to leave
was it me we did yeah means god I'm
amazed at that I'm amazed that that
surprises me we dead that's a beautiful
baby
oh let me get this one flapping flapping
freebie I'm swinging left or right
you're in the nutty Oh God
so a nutty buddy oh if you're in the
nutty with you buddy we did you have any
enjoys sex
ah he's our Reggie oh so close you got
the food isn't Reggie he's a root right
eyes are right root anything that moves
oh that sounds a criminal back is
because you wear those on your feet yeah
and then we went to Mecca oh you went to
McDonald's yeah what do you call Burger
King mmm Burger King
stubby that's a smaller action
it's also what we call a bottle of beer
yes that's what I meant
you've taught me I've listened and I
think I have it okay okay so Mabel do a
little role-playing scenario right now
sure oh she laughs you know hey go get
her a top note see that oh thanks top
shelf Sheila look stubby yoga stubby
sure Cheers
yeah Cheers hello the froth off for you
ah yeah
jeez like you stubby there it's the red
car that's listening to a Kadapa Oh
brilliant yeah and I got all sighted and
you know went out and suddenly I'm lost
and I'm you know got hungry and I went
to Mecca you went to Mecca yeah because
I didn't didn't want to go to Burger
King with Akkad acha yeah I'm a roadie
who likes Rutten I'm a routing roadies
Oaxaca Dhaka I'm not rooting I'm
sleeping I'm getting me zzs I'm having a
bit of a Kip and getting me zzs the saws
ease of the logs ease and then when I'm
awake I'm a routing grew track we did
think I'm a pirate I just thought maybe
I was swimming and new will be out of
date but I was in me budgie smugglers so
I had to but that's a sight to behold
ah sight for sore eyes Oh your eyes
would be saw if you saw that many
budgies in one smuggler I think you
would have maced me by now
[Laughter]
[Applause]